you know that the the White House is
saying look uh we're not going to
negotiate uh this is a fake negotiation
we're uh just going to ask for a clean
uh debt limit increase and I do not
think McCarthy and the Republicans can
deliver a clean debt limit increase
after everything they've been through I
think it would cost McCarthy's
speakership
um so so I don't think they are going to
get a clean debt limit increase like so
something's going to have to give but
what happened last time was it was a big
robust okay there's never been a crisis
like this everyone meaning everyone in
DC kind of fueled by these these
pressure groups everyone's talking about
the debt we should do something and
that's not been happening this time
because everyone in Washington lived
through a trump Administration that once
it was in power got rid of the spending
spending caps as part of those debt
deals just kept kept plowing ahead and
spending money but Republicans are not
even going as as broad as they did 12
years ago like they went out of their
way this time to not touch any
entitlement program in the deal so the
and I can actually I should I could
truncate what I'm saying because in 2011
the idea was this is so unprecedented
this is the time to do gigantic reforms
that we all agree America must do it's
been overdue that's not the debate this
time it's okay well we need to give into
some demands Republicans have some
things that they want to cut and reverse
they want to get reverse Parts the
inflation reduction act
um they want permitting reform uh they
want to claw back and spent coveted
money it is less than Republicans were
demanding less time last time because
just I think things have changed and
they're post-trump the Republican party
is not interested in entitlement reform
Social Security costs Medicare Cuts
Medicaid Cuts sure but but not the rest
of it so it's a very it's a much smaller
debate which is which is also playing
into this you're not as as invested if
you're watching this from the outside
from Wall Street because
the the deal a deal that would make
Democrats unhappy that would make
Republicans feel like they won something
um you just started to describe it it
would be well we cut we cut some of
Biden's spending priorities and we we
have some environmental uh policies that
Democrats didn't want that we got
through that wouldn't be enormous that
really that stuff that honestly well
functioning Congress could probably just
vote vote on normal shirt like the old
congresses of 50 years ago could just
say well here comes a crisis what can we
trade so the stakes are the stakes are
lower and it's a much
I want to say silly um but it's it's
it's having a tougher time getting into
the public Consciousness for all those
reasons you know people live through it
Stakes are lower there's less being
demanded and the white and Democrats are
convinced all right if we just don't
treat this like it's legitimate that's
never we've never tried that before
we've never we've never just pretended
that this isn't real we can't enough to
negotiate what will happen if we hold
out as long as possible
well I I do want to to uh say on one
level the stakes are higher my read of
the situation is that
um they're going to play chicken uh and
um and that they're not going to do the
reasonable thing until they're forced to
do so and by the time they're forced to
do so I think there could be some
significant repercussions I think the
Market's Fragile with these bank
failures and the rest of it I think
confidence is fragile uh like you know
that this is just like going to be a
self-inflicted wound
um if they get to a point where it
starts having a real Market
repercussions how do you think this
plays out so one possibility is the
White House gets to the precipice and
says all right uh none of this is real
we're going to find a way to keep
funding the government and we're not
going to be taking Hospital hostage in
other ways is that is that aka the
trillion dollar coin yeah I mean that
they say they can't pull off but I'm
saying until until we reach that moment
and they officially rule it out you
can't 100 rule that out before the other
options are are much more pedestrian and
and and normal which is okay we we
reached this point in negotiation
willing to sign off on a few after not
negotiating roller sign of a few things
they wanted which is I've not negotiated
many debt limit deals or many of these
deals like this but being obstinate
saying absolutely nothing and then
giving part of what Republicans want um
and then at that point maybe you throw
it to the house and you can put the onus
on Republicans in the house
um will they pass something that's less
than what they demanded and to the
extent the the the the gamesmanship of
this is I believe that's that's where
our after the story at the moment the
one one thing I will say though
the Democratic base which remember the
same position where Barack Obama's
running for re-election in 2011 2012. uh
the threat was that Republicans might
tank the economy while he's running for
re-election uh Biden is running for
re-election just announced it the
through the threat is similar but
there's less apart from just the losing
face there are fewer things being
negotiated that would anger the
Democratic base there was a possibility
that Obama could have gone in let's say
one of the versions of the of the debt
limit deal had passed Obama could go in
as the first Democratic president to
agree to uh in a very long time on
social security cuts
um what would that have done to the
excitement of the base what would that
what would that have done to democratic
activists we saw how within four years
there was a a primary challenge to
Hillary Clinton there was the Bernie
Sanders campaign what would that have
done I think it would have disrupted
things with inside the party I don't
think anything being negotiated right
now will disrupt things the same way
there would be disappointment by a lot
of liberals uh who say why the president
looks weak for having compromised at all
he should have minted the coin uh I
think mythical coin is a good like way
to just say he should have done
something that just cuts get rid of the
whole controversy but it wouldn't be the
same thing like he betrayed he betrayed
us I think there would if they're a
permanent reform is something that a lot
of Democrats were going to agree to
anyway I think there will be would be a
backlash from the environmental left on
that uh but most the backlash would be
we don't like it when our team loses
less we don't like it when our team
undermines the the New Deal that was the
risk in 2012 2011.
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang-up new
guest thank you